what's going on guys
transformers age of extinction is
rolling into theaters shortly
transformers might be the most popular
robots right now but there are some
other cool awesome robots out there and
we're talking about that very subject
today we have a cool panel to talk about
the stuff with us for she's a good
friend of mine
you know her from whose line is it
anyway Heather Anne Campbell hi how are
you
and this handsome chap is an actor a
comedian Mike Carl's thank you thank you
rib so today we're gonna be talking
about robots and before you leave
hateful comments we know that some of
these are droids
some are replicant some are computers
all right we're using the sweeping term
robots and if you don't like it too bad
Mike a robot that you're a fan o a robot
I'm a fan of rocky for rocky buys Paulie
a robots
for his birthday please make a wish it's
creepy that talks that take there's a
theory on the internet that Paulie
changes the gender of the robot mid
movie in order to have sex with it
what it's my favorite you're the
greatest
she loves me oh you had man vs.
technology but then you had man uniting
with technology as Paulie made love to a
robot that is correct
yeah so you got the message of the film
one of my favorite all-time robots is
the t1000 Robert Patrick and Terminator
2 they tried on Nickelodeon to imitate
that with the I believe it was the
Secret World of Alex Mack which was a
show about a preteen I think who has
same t1000 powers but that's like the
closest we've gotten to something that
cool in that way what and it's not cool
what a dark pitch that would be it's
like Terminator for children yes all
right Heather I don't know if this is a
robot or if he's clockwork but Bubo from
the original clash of shite night was
also a huge robot friend of a robot
friend of mine he's like r2d2 but a bird
but let me ask you this in Clash of the
Titans how did that technology exist
back then
first off
the movies not a documentary so none of
those things happen like there was no
there's no winget horse what about the
Krakken the Cragin is not real did you
come here today to on my beliefs no
no how no I just okay another one I feel
like I would be remiss if I did not
mention how from Stanley Kubrick's 2001
a Space Odyssey open the pod bay doors
hell I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that there was a
real through line in the late seventies
of like mother uh an alien was the
computer AI oh yeah yeah you know like
mother why are we going to this place
that's wrong about ten years after I
know Bill yeah I was like this constant
like paranoia about the one the one mind
robot that might screw us all over that
we were building our own oblivion yeah
yes your turn so let's switch gears and
talk about robots we're not really fans
of I'll throw kind of just an appalling
pair out there mudflap and skids from
transformers 2 it's hard to believe that
it made it a movie
what were they before they were robots
they started out as an ice cream truck
and then because of the importance of
Commerce and product placement became
Chevy branded vehicles can you read this
reeves now what we know we don't really
do much Wheaton Mike a robot that you
hate I hate and love but hate the robot
be 4 which is data's brother from Star
Trek 10 nemesis he was the robot that
went wrong literally the end of the Star
Trek The Next Generation movies is
Picard and before singing blue skies Oh
God
shining so bright I don't like ash from
alien and here's why when technology
starts moving really fast people are
going to think oh this is gonna be like
that thing an alien that chokes people
and like shove magazines in their mouths
well it's a weird way to kill somebody I
guarantee that when a robot goes amuck
on Drudge Report the screenshot will be
ash trying to kill Ripley that is
awesome
all right so we've hit a bunch but there
are so many great ones I'll just throw
out some names and you give me any
thoughts c-3po and r2d2 there are a lot
of scrapes in the original trilogy that
he could have been like hey I can fly I
flew all the time like 20 years ago yeah
why did that not happen cuz he's just a
jerk I mean if you see him it's just
like a little troll like then it's great
cuz then it's like oh he could totally
get them out of this like listen to him
it's not what a second so I talked about
the t1000 who just like was mind-blowing
ly badass let's talk about the
Terminator that in the first one he is
just frightening
I just lost like clips of this when I
was a kid cuz I couldn't watch the whole
thing so I was too scared but like I saw
him as the metal skeleton for a second
and it was that was it magma fuel yeah
that was it absolutely it's great way to
put it what about Roy batty from Blade
Runner Blade Runner was the first movie
I bought on blu-ray uh it's my favorite
movie of all time
I have those all the replicants are so
awesome ol dumb moments will be lost
in time like tears and rain replicant
writes replicant writes cool and
justified yep
guys we talked about a lot of robots
droids and computers who'd we leave out
what did we leave out tell us your
favorite in the comments section below
best answer you're gonna get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank my
awesome panel Heather Anne Campbell Mike
Carlson follow them on Twitter hit me up
on Twitter we'll talk movies and whatnot
I'm Hal Rudnick thanks for watching bye
bye
talk to me a little bit about the coming
out of their shells someone said how do
we make money with turtle if it donate
more money that's more money with Ninja
Turtles let's have him start a fan so
they had to coming out of the shelter
which was this was a big thing